i know that but i think i feel a little
more
pressured even my family is like so are
you guys sleeping together or not i'm
like no we're not
and like he's never said i need an
answer but i'll just feel like
he needs an answer so like what are we
doing to get back together or
not to get back together that is the
question
okay so that definitely wasn't the
question shakespeare had in mind
but it is the question on khloe
kardashian's mind
they're great i mean we're in a really
good
place he's been super helpful and when i
was
isolated he helped with so many
responsibilities but i can also tell
like his energy is different like he'll
like you know touch my shoulders or
something like okay you're getting a
little too touchy
on the season 19 finale of keeping up
with the kardashians
coco opens up about her hesitation to
reconcile with her
ex tristan thompson during a chat with
her bestie malika
it's like i just want you to know if
ever you are
thinking the same thing i'm here for you
basically like i'm just gonna know the
door is open
yes just a refresher the two split in
2019
after tristan's cheating scandal with
kylie jenner's former bestie jordan
woods
you know things happen and of course i'm
sorry but they made sure to build a
positive co-parenting relationship for
their two-year-old daughter true it's
a beautiful thing to get along with each
other and for your kids to see that
and as the two quarantined together amid
the coronavirus pandemic
chloe admits she was feeling pressured
to start things back up again
i do feel pressure from tristan but not
because he's
told me you need to give me like i've
never had an ultimatum from tristan
i just feel like it's been over a year
since we broke up and
now that we're hanging out more i can
tell he's getting antsy
guys the internal struggle is real i
just
wish i had a definitive answer on my end
like i wish
i either said all these feelings for
tristan i just am afraid or
gosh i don't have any feelings that's
like i don't even know how to get a
feeling back
any feeling because you're scared and
you're blocking out your feelings about
those things because it's just safe
i think you're just not open to being
loved
because of all of this that has happened
[Music]
yeah the 36 year old who also previously
went through a
very public divorce from her ex lamar
odom
said she's been burned one too many
times and it'll take a lot of patience
for someone to tear down the walls she's
built up
i 100 have a block up but who wouldn't
like every relationship i go into
they're always
disappointing and dumb so i have every
reason
to be guarded i have every reason to
have these
bricks up in layers and if somebody
cares enough
they will take those bricks down but
guys spoiler alert
back in august et learned that tristan
and chloe had reignited their romance
i'm really just enjoying my life at the
time a source told et the couple is back
together and things have been going
really well i'm just super happy and
content last month
tristan joined chloe and her famous
family on sister kim kardashian's
tropical 40th birthday getaway
and even did a little dance off with
mama kris jenner's beau
corey gamble
of course fans of the family's hit
reality show can expect to watch it all
unfold on tv starting with the season 19
finale thursday keeping up will come
back for its 20th and final season in
early 2021
you